hi I'm Alex so today I'm gonna be making
a galaxy mirror cake we've actually made
a mirror cake before on tasty I have not
personally I think I can do this no no I
should have done that oh I'm pretty
confident
[Music]
so I'm gonna start with a boxed cake mix
now I know everyone is going to be up in
arms about this but feel free to make
your own cake recipe at home don't want
your cakes to stick in your pan always
grease now I'm gonna do the vanilla
buttercream buttercream is super easy to
make and it's very delicious it's just
like a ton of butter and sugar
I hope this bowl is big enough okay the
mixers going rogue whoo frostings done
cakes are done it's time to assemble
kind of dreading this part how hard
could be right i greased the pan so
that's a good start
oh no I greased this my crease entrance
so I just want to cut enough off the top
of the cake that it's not like mounded
over the top not the smoothest so I know
a way you get crumbs into your frosting
is if you pick up your spatula so I'm
gonna try not to pick it up scrape this
down
okay there you go exactly what you
aren't supposed to do I feel like this
is hypnotizing me this is just me
putting off getting to the next step
which I know is where I'm probably gonna
mess it up okay so now for the most
dreaded part the glades it's actually
pretty simple that was a little hot it's
funny because I actually like much
prefer cooking to baking but I feel like
I keep doing tasty videos that are
really intense baking things okay now
I'm gonna wait for it to boil Oh takes
you on the glaze I'm gonna watch it
carefully does it boil this time oh stop
going oh my god it's good okay I'm using
these fancy gelatin sheets
it's weird cuz like the middle is so
hard but then the outsides are all like
jelly I realized what I did wrong I was
supposed to put them in as like single
sheets I think it's best if I resume
this on Monday try to get the water out
oh that's really weird okay it's in
there I think it's already melted in
that was quick I have my chocolate now
ideally you should use above 30% cocoa
butter white chocolate I think I got the
wrong kind the cool thing about this
glaze though is that you can make a head
if you need to and then just heat it
back up when you want to use it we're
going in so I guess this is to get like
any lumps out because you want your
glaze to be like super silky and smooth
so I'm going to take this glaze that we
just made and separate it into these
five different poles and so one is gonna
be like a dark blue-black that's like a
nice Twilight blue I think I want to do
like a midnight
and I'm gonna do a navy blue a lighter
blue a purple and a pink okay so I'm
taking the temperature of the glaze it
looks like it's a little too cold it's
about 82 so I'm gonna mix the darkest
color we have with the second darkest
color we have and I'm not gonna mix it
fully okay here we go people
Stewart I literally I'm about to have a
heart attack I really hope this works if
it doesn't work then yeah I don't know
what I'm gonna do now I'm gonna go over
it with some lighter blue oh that's sick
click the Milky Way look II wear pink I
have to do this fast really like we oh I
should have done that
and that would just be like a black hole
[Music]
have you been to space for you no I
don't think so
Bob you know yeah so it's just the top I
was trying to like Mel the colors but
I've waited too long and it's that
already and now I just ruined it
okay I have to go right now because it's
at the perfect temperature okay there's
a wait okay I'll get it okay we've got
some planets we've got some shooting
stars hey what happened to the side I
put on extra deodorant this morning
because I knew I would be really inches
[Music]
I think outside seems recovered
I'm literally like I wish you could see
me shaking right now because I'm like
freaking out but it's looking really
good so now I actually went and got
white food coloring so I can do the
stars looks like an actual galaxy feel
like Bob Ross right now the hair from
the bush wait I leave it away we common
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's time to say goodbye to the skank
and cut into it I'm a little sad to be
honest because it looks really good and
now I have to ruin it but it's had its
run I did it galaxy mirror cake was a
lot harder than I anticipated I'm
currently on a diet so I'm not even
going to eat this but it looks good and
that's what counts so until next time
[Music]
don't we just go okay I think the no
Jackson Pollock cake
[Music]